germany is extending its coronavirus
lockdown until april 18th as it grapples
with the third wave of the pandemic
the move comes after talks between
chancellor angela mackel and regional
leaders ran
into the early hours of the morning
leaders were at loggerheads over whether
to ease restrictions on domestic travel
over the easter holiday season
ultimately agreeing on a five-day strict
national shutdown over the period
mackel says the caranovirus crisis in
germany has taken a dangerous turn
we basically have a new pandemic
the mutation from great britain has
taken over
which means we have a new virus
of course of the same kind but with very
different
properties it is clearly more lethal
more contagious
and contagious for longer our
correspondent thomas sparrow is covering
this story for us thomas
germany is tightening restrictions in
the face of what chancellor angela
merkel is calling
a new pandemic what are we looking at
here
terry that's a remarkable statement by
the german chancellor
after hours of discussion with regional
leaders after
a very controversial meeting in the
german chancellery behind me
which included several hours where they
weren't meeting where there was a
division let's say in that sense so it
just gives you an idea of how difficult
the situation has become when it comes
to the coronavirus numbers to those
to that exponential rise in infections
it also gives you an idea of just
how controversial the whole situation is
how difficult it is for leaders
to find consensus by the way there's
also difficulty to find consensus in
german
society if you look exactly at some of
the polls that have come out in recent
days
if you ask specifically what was decided
you can divide it in
certain aspects one is the extension of
some of the restrictions that are
already in place until
mid-april that includes for example
cultural or sport venues remaining
close second pulling that handbrake as
it's been described here in other words
those areas that are particularly
affected will have to reverse some of
the opening steps that had been decided
a few weeks ago and third you already
mentioned it as well that particular
lockdown
over easter which by the way terry was
one of the main reasons
why regional and federal leaders could
not agree yesterday and why
these discussions went actually into
well into the night and why we're now
discussing this
early in the morning after those very
very long talks
are these measures thomas likely to be
enough to really stem the country's
third wave of infections
isn't it too little too late yet again
well certainly there's a sense of
frustration among the german population
there's a certain
uncertainty especially by those who do
not see a light at the end of the tunnel
but if you ask those who
were meeting yesterday at the german
chancellery they certainly believe
that this can help to reduce numbers in
particular
when we talk about that lockdown over
easter
but there is a lot of criticism as well
and again if you look at some of the
polls that have come out in in recent
days before the announcement yesterday
you will see that people are divided as
to what should be the cause of action
for germany
especially if you consider on the one
hand those high infection numbers but on
the other hand the fact that germany is
going through a very slow vaccination
process a vaccination process which by
the way was described as
the way out of the pandemic so there is
on the one hand hope
that vaccinations will help but there's
also frustration by the way that it's
all going here in germany
thomas thank you very much as our
political correspondent thomas sparrow
well for even more we're joined now by
mikhail toira he's the deputy leader of
the opposition free democrats in
germany's parliament the bundestag and
party leader in the state of
baden-wurttemberg thanks for being with
us this morning mr toiler
now you've previously criticized the
government's coronavirus
strategy what do you make of these
latest measures
yeah good morning first of all um the
latest uh
measures they took a really long time to
be
approved by the minister presidents and
the chancery
we think it is it has both positive
outcomes and negative outcomes
what we are in favor is a german-wide
standard which is implemented regionally
that is mainly guaranteed now
but we don't have a convincing answer
on the biggest issues that is the test
capacity which is still too
low and the whole process of testing
is too slow and the second is that the
vaccination process
uh which was mentioned by a reporter uh
is not yet with the same speed
implemented
like we can see in the united kingdom of
course in the united states of america
i want to ask you about that in just a
moment the vaccination rolled out which
is
uh very controversial but but first
about these measures that have just been
decided do you think that the german
government really had any
alternative at this point
yes they have and they should have
implemented
this plan of uh step-by-step
opening or closing a bit earlier so what
is not convincing
anybody is that there are rich
that there are instructions on on on
on traveling um because
if we look at the infection
infections in hotels or even
in restaurants there is
the the robert koch institute tells us
that there is not a major risk
there and therefore we are completely in
favor
of a strategy which
which is more to the target and which
will not end up
in general lockdown your party
has championed a plan to gradually
reopen the economy you just talked about
restaurants uh
and maybe things should have been done
earlier but is it realistic
to open the economy given the risks to
public health
um we see both the risks but we also
uh have to have an opportunity and a
perspective
uh for the traders uh for the retailers
and especially for hotels and
restaurants in areas
in counties where the incidence rate is
still low and we have
model regions like the university town
of tubingen
where there is a testing strategy rolled
out which is leading
to a significantly lower incidence rate
and we do not understand
why the german health minister jens
spahn and the chancellor angela merkel
did not help to
roll out this successful strategy of
tubingen
to all all over the place in in germany
mr toilet thank you very much for
talking with us today that was michelle
toila from the free democrats
member of the german bundestag